Voiceover: I want to use this
video to try to get a better
intuition for futures curves
and in particular to understand
that the futures curves
shows a snapshot in time
of the different market
prices for the, essentially
the delivery price at different
future dates and when I
say that, I know it was a
kind of confusing statement.
In this futures curve right over here,
when you have a delivery date
that's 0 months from now,
that's essentially today,
that's the market price.
That is the actual market
price of that commodity.
In this example, the commodity is silver.
So if you were to go out
and buy silver today,
it would cost you roughly
$32, let me say that this is
per ounce. It would
cost you $32 per ounce.
When I say one out here, this is one month
in the future. I'm not
talking about the price.
I'm not talking about the spot
price of silver in a month.
I'm talking about the
price today in the market,
if you were to agree to buy
or sell silver in a month.
The futures price for a
delivery one month out,
that's what that is right now.
So I want to make it very
clear. This is not showing you
how the spot price of silver will
move over the next eight months.
It's telling you today. If you
wanted to transact in silver
right now, you would
transact at $32 an ounce.
If today you agree to transact
in silver a month from now,
you would transact, you would buy or sell,
it looks at around $33 an ounce.
If today you were to agree
to buy or sell silver
four months from now, you
would do it at $35 an ounce.
If today, I don't want to
be redundant, but if today
you were to agree buy or sell
silver eight months from now
and you were to lock in the
price, you would lock in a
price, it looks it about I
don't know, $36 an ounce.
So this is really a snapshot
in time and if for example,
let's say tomorrow, the price
of silver, there's this huge
silver shortage or people
realize a new application for
silver that can change the
world then what you would have
tomorrow is that this whole
curve would probably shift up.
The whole curve would shift
up something like that,
so no matter when you decide
to actually transact in
the silver, it'll actually get
more expensive but I want to
make it very clear that this
is just a snapshot in time
and to better understand that,
I've also drawn over here
how the prices can move it
over time and I've drawn
different durations. So
in purple right over here,
I've drawn the spot price. So
this is the spot price today
and over here, this is the spot
price today but then I've shown
how it changes in time. So
this is kind of closer to a
traditional stock chart. This
just tells us that look, the stock
price started at $32 and went
up a little bit, went down
a little bit. It kind of just
goes up and down, oscillates
a bit over the next eight
months. So this is actual
movement over time. This is
a snapshot of delivery dates
at some point in the future.
So the spot price just moves
around and let's just take this
green contract right over here.
So when we start on the first
day, the green contract,
if you agree to transact in
silver four months from now,
you're agreeing to transact at about $34.
So that's where you
would transact right now,
that four month out contract,
but as you move few -
as you move more and more forward in time,
you're getting closer and
closer to that delivery date.
If you move one month into the future,
now that contract is only
going to be three months out.
You move two months in the future,
now that contract is only two months out.
All the way until, if
you move four months out,
this contract will now be
essentially the spot price
because you're now
agreeing to transact now.
That'll happen four months
from now, but you'll now
be agreeing to transact at that
moment and so at that moment,
that price should be the
same as the spot price,
so you'll have this
convergent with the spot price
and the same thing for the
eight month out contract,
it should converge over
the next eight months.